I guarantee you that at some point
everything's gonna go south on you now
you can either accept that or you can
get to work
Ridley Scott's epic the Martian is one
of the most exciting space films since
gravity it's been a good year for space
New Horizons flew past Pluto and got
everyone excited about the dwarf planet
on the International Space Station
astronauts are eating lettuce they grew
themselves and NASA's found new evidence
of water on Mars throw into that mix a
slate of highly anticipated space works
and it's a very very good year for space
fans the recent discovery of water on
Mars cast a film in a bit of a strange
light part of the plot revolves around
Matt Damon's character Mark Watney
needed to synthesize water in order to
survive on the barren planet after his
crew of astronauts escapes leaves him
stranded and left for dead but while
we've seen survival in space stories
before Center Pollock to leap frogging
between space capsules and gravity or
Tom Hanks in Apollo 13
we always love a good hero versus a
hostile alien world scenario and the
Martian has got plenty of boat ma won't
he's still alive Wow in your face Neil
Armstrong unlike mark Watney Ridley
Scott actually seems to be having fun on
Mars offering up beautiful landscapes
from the Red Planet or at least it's
terrestrial stand in Jordan and plenty
of tension to go along with it it takes
a lot to carry the bulk of a two-hour
movie by yourself and Matt Damon brings
the right blend of scientists gravitas
and deadpan wit to his portrayal of Mark
Watney the botanist who stranded on Mars
but I am the greatest botanist on this
planet he might be alone on the planet
but he's not alone in the film which has
great performances by Jessica Chastain
as the astronaut crews come
Chiwetel Ejiofor is nasa's head of mars
missions and jeff daniels as the
director of NASA Donald Glover also has
a great small performance in a role I
don't want to spoil for you while the
Martian expertly adapted by Drew Goddard
from Andy Weir's fan favorite originally
self-published book is sci-fi at least
for now
it's looted in extensively researched
science from botany to orbital mechanics
so as much as it is a rollicking story
it's also something of a promotion for
that manned mission to Mars that so many
of us are waiting to see it's your move
NASA I'm gonna have to science the hell
out of this